I can't drink green tea but I can put
the teabags
on my eyes I drink some form of caffeine
every day I'm pretty aware of how I
can't function without caffeine so this
is it is my last one
I guess the only time that I don't have
caffeine in my system is what I'm
sleeping I've been drinking coffee since
I was seven I was asked by my doctor to
stop drinking coffee now as a few months
ago and I have not I just want to know
that I can do this and the world will
continue to spin I'm making it through
my first day pretty okay like I'm not
super exhausted I don't have crazy bags
under my eyes
typically I'll get a coffee on the way
to work today I get nothing if I don't
drink coffee I feel tired I just came
home for lunch a little sad because I
don't feel like I can be around people
I'm pretty useless as a person without
caffeine the second day and I'm dead
already
look at this you kind of can't quit
something unless you actually want to
quit it more irritated that I can't have
something
versus the fact that I'm not drinking
caffeinated so it's a three or four I
can't be sure anymore
I'm definitely eating more literally my
best friend this week 11:15 and I'm
driving they don't feel safe being about
to first set do I seem weird to you yeah
you seem dumb
I've been super irritable this entire
week and I'm like so mad I'm so on edge
and every little thing irritates me I
think my biggest challenge now this was
just finding things that I could drink I
was given this tumeric tonic taste is
kind of like curry water it's Monday
morning I'm feeling hopeful that I'm not
gonna drink coffee I could barely think
sometimes like at the end of the day
part of me was just missing definitely
excited for no coffee for a coffee to
cook I can't I can't think I can't think
I don't want to say I didn't have a
purpose
I just been doing a lot of like internal
screaming don't have ache I really
thought this would be easier I couldn't
go a day without Advil it's crazy how
big a role it plays in my life I know
that I function as like a shadow of a
human being without coffee but I didn't
realize how deep it was what's been cool
about this whole experience is that I've
learned that I definitely don't need
caffeine for energy I am way more
addicted to coffee than I even realized
I forgot I forgot and I made it it was
instinct school and it's delicious dr.
what I did it I can confidently say I
can go a week without touching any bit
of caffeine I got over the headaches I
got over like the fatigue and the
irritability and cut back so I don't
feel like a complete failure if you ever
feel like you are addicted to something
or are controlled by something you
should definitely try to like take a
step back and see if you really are I as
a person don't want to be dependent on
anything if you really want to stop
doing something then think about it just
our to our day by day
glad I did this but I love caffeine and
I'm not sorry about it I'm having green
tea and it's amazing I missed it so much
wow this is the greatest thing ever